foreign
speaker was supposed to be the amazing
creative filmmaker from La Zach King but
unfortunately uh he's gone missing we've
been trying to track track him down and
ah
hey I'm so I'm so sorry I'm not at the
conference I'm not gonna make it I'm
stuck at the airport but uh they want to
let me in with this apparently it's
oversized but uh wait you're on stage
hold on I have an idea
phone down here
this might be
oh
hey
sorry I'm late people have said Zach
King
I'm glad that worked because sometimes I
get stuck in the screen and it becomes a
whole thing
I have a question for you this morning
what is this
you can answer a box yeah I asked a lot
of people that question and most people
say it's a box
but I've met a small group of people who
have told me that this is not a box and
what's fascinating about this group of
people is they're the ones that a
pioneered space travel explored the
depths of our oceans and created some of
the most impenetrable fortresses all
before the age of five of course I'm
talking about my kids
see when I showed him this they told me
that this was not a box but rather a
rocket ship a submarine and a castle all
at once somehow combined
so why is it that you and I as adults we
look at something like this and we just
call it what it is a box
but our children they can see it for
more possibilities
over the past decade as a filmmaker I've
been on a quest to see what this child
like Wonder again so now when I see
something such as a pool table
well I see an entirely different type of
pool
and I I no longer see a little soccer
ball here it's actually got some life to
it it's a little Dalmatian puppy
I no longer see the light the glasses
half empty in fact I don't even see a
glass at all for me it's actually a
tasty piece of chocolate cake
see you and I can still access this
child like Wonder we can still see and
dream with this Wonder although it may
have been a while since we've
experienced it so today what I want to
do for you is have you regain your sense
of child like Wonder and show you how to
do that so if you will I want to tell
you a story and I invite you to imagine
with me
that one Christmas a box just like this
is wrapped and placed under a tree
and an excited little boy comes running
down the stairs on Christmas morning and
he unwraps the box and inside
is a bike
and although he rides the bike for a few
moments around the room
he ends up playing with the Box instead
because to him it's a deep dark cave
hello
and at the bottom of that cave is an x
marks the spot and of course he's the
best pirate on the Seas so he's gonna
dig for buried treasure
it's a lot of work digging for treasure
and that's when he discovered
that he ah
that he was not the first pirate to look
for this treasure
but that boy had many adventures with
this box over the years once it was his
time machine that took him back to the
age of the dinosaurs
another time it was actually his bunker
to hide from the zombie apocalypse
and once he even dreamed that it was a
submarine that took him to the depths of
the ocean until he could no longer hold
his breath
but one day the boy couldn't find the
box he looked in his room he searched
the backyard
and then he found it in the garage and
he when he ran to go play with it he
opened it up and
inside were winter jackets
and this was the day that the boy
learned what the box was actually made
to do
to store things
now the box is just a regular box
the boy ended up
packing up his things to go to college
in that box a couple years later
soon after that he used that box to move
to his first home when he got married
and then after that to make room for the
baby he packed some of his film gear in
this box placed it in the top shelf of
his garage where it sat for a while
collecting dust
see I was that boy and I'm embarrassed
to admit that that box sat on the top
shelf of the garage for many more years
after that not being dreamed with
so
one night I heard a sound
it was coming from the garage and I
thought someone was breaking in so I
went to go check it out to my surprise
the box is on the ground and my kids
were dreaming with the Box
and they said daddy we're playing rocket
ship come play with us
it had been a while since I played the
with the box but I fired on the engine
for him sure enough after all these
years he still ran
and we headed to space
Houston we're ready for liftoff
we ended up going just a little past
Jupiter where we met some friendly space
aliens who taught us a really cool sport
that I want to show you called space
soccer
it's a really slow sport requires a lot
of yoga
but it is more fun than golf
so
it was there in that garage that I
learned the key to why all our kids see
with childlike Wonder
it's because they don't have assumptions
they don't have assumptions about the
box yet they haven't been told what it's
supposed to do or what it's supposed to
be used for therefore they have all
these other possibilities
so for you and I
as we approach life and and try to solve
new problems if we're able to remove our
assumptions for a moment we can see with
this new childlike Wonder once again so
I want to test this out and see if this
worked if this experience regained a
little sense of your Wonder so I'm going
to throw up my desktop image on the
screen and I want you to hold back your
assumptions
so on the desktop screen you might have
a few assumptions that you can't hold
back like some of you I know you're
looking at it going uh I'm really
disorganized or you're assuming that
I've got too many projects going on and
both of those are are true but I want us
to look a little deeper to see the
possibility so let me help clear the way
here
I was actually looking at the background
maybe I need a vacation you know it's
actually super nice here
hey
I'll take that
so the next time somebody tells you it's
oh
wait
that doesn't make sense
how do I get out of here
this out
Fox
maybe it's something else entirely
Maybe
foreign
it's a portal
so the next time
so the next time somebody tells you to
think outside the box
you can tell them hey this is not a box
because when you remove our assumptions
we're able to then see what this
childlike sense of wonder
and that's the moment when new ideas can
enter the world
[Applause]
[Music]